and marcus uh off the one hitter as we
mentioned in the open eight strong
innings when needed four and oh
lifetimings against these braves ozzy
albee's the second place hitter for the
braves fifth in rbis another ground ball
this one finds a hole and ozzy just puts
it in play that's his seventh hit of the
road trip left-handers two for 12 off
mueller right-handers hitting 164. it's
the walks have been his bugaboo and he
walks vr leading off as he did in his
first start against the mets off to a
great start
little fly ball shallow left arcia
coming in
and he'll get there to make the catch
three fly ball outs after a lead off
walk to retire the side no score after
one two and two now the pitch swung out
and missed strike three side retired got
him with a sinker at 91 for stroman his
first strikeout and the braves go in
order two balls two strikes and pilar
chased a breaking ball that's the first
strikeout for mueller he's set down five
in a row
and that one's scorched toward right
center but it's gonna be tracked down in
front of the bullpen and it's three up
three down for mueller in a scoreless
second the duel continues in game one
guillermo heredia leads off the third
against marcus strowman
and a
shot to left past dom smith he can't
find it the ball trampolines out of the
glove
and heredia will stand at second base
that's the second atlanta base runner
and the braves a chance to strike first
here in the third inning to the braves
pitcher who stands in the box
drew the bat back and grounds it through
the left side it's a base hit already is
going to slam on the brakes as smith got
to it quickly and kyle muller has his
first big league hit
a slug bunt and atlanta's got him first
and third with nobody out mets are
playing a double play depth up the
middle they'd concede the run for a
double play ball here
smoke tort right and fair into the
corner one run scores let's see mueller
run he's on his way to third they're
going to put up a stop sign second and
third nobody out and the braves strike
first on a bullet from jack peterson
he's got the pitcher mueller at third
peterson at second freeman at first
one out
strowman looking for the ground ball
from riley who hit a ground ball his
first time up and he grounds one to
short should be two vr nikki or man on
the first end time double play side
retired
so now strowman two for 31 at the plate
this year and it drops down a bunt
riley with the bare hand can't make the
play and strowman's got a bunt head i
mean you can't drop a bunt or a third
any better than that and strumming with
the good wheels might have beaten it out
anyway but riley couldn't make the pick
up
two balls and two strikes on alonso two
on one out third inning the mets down a
run the pitch
swing and a tip into the glove of vote
strike three payoff pitch
struck cam out what a job by mueller a
10 pitch at batty wins that battle he
strands a pair of mets and he sends game
one of this doubleheader to the fourth
inning with his braves in front dance me
this month 444 on base percentage when
leading off an inning
and dansby cracks one toward deep center
pilar back that one is off the top of
the wall dansby just missed a home run
he hit it 407 feet
and now they say home run
[Applause]
dansby's going back to second
[Applause]
doug eddings called him off yeah he
overruled it yeah that was
a double all the way
infield shortens up with two strikes
just to touch the pitch
it's on the ground diving stop ball
bobbled by vr they get one and that's
all a run is in it's two nothing the
braves make contact and extend the lead
pitch to all beings lifted in the air to
left field towards the line comes smith
still coming slides and makes the catch
lost his camp in the process
ball kept working its way away from dumb
and he had to turn on the jets and use
the slide machine
and it worked for him and he got all
these for the second out hollers walked
only one that was his first batter
tonight
vr in the first
drury cracks one to deep left center
back in the gap goes garcia
and it'll short hop the wall
and drury pulls into second base with
another pinch hit double he had one on
saturday
and he's got another one
still got a hanger here that's first
extra base end of the day good strong
take back he's just such a strong guy
get that in the air that had been out of
here even he clocked this drury at
second vr at first
and alonso on the ground right he steps
on the bag throws to first into double
play
pete alonso head bombing it all is all
for three he's stranded three runners
mueller is through five and the braves
lead game one two to nothing they'll
last pitched on saturday a scoreless
inning against toronto and a good
breaking ball by
castro to strike out vote for the first
down and that slider in on him and he
was toast pitch
swinging a missed strike three nasty
slider there from castro arcia was
confused out in front of it and an
awkward swing miguel castro with
back-to-back strikeouts 1-2 to sandoval
and the slider in for a call third
strike
castro fans three in the inning and
sends us to the bottom of the sixth with
the meds still down two nothing yankees
tomorrow
one-two pitch swung out and missed
strike three got him with a slider
castro has struck out four
and with two out nobody on it'll bring
up freddie freeman and a line drive into
right field that's headed for the corner
conforto cuts it off freeman will settle
for his second single of the game one
two coming
breaking ball popped up
and vr waiting for it to come down
that retires aside two scoreless innings
for miguel castro last licks for the
match in game one down tuna just enough
offense partner for will smith to carry
a two-run lead into the bottom of the
seventh inning to left pretty well hit
almonte to the wall over ran it but
recovered that was close
pallar gave it a ride but he's out
number one nino to center field that
will fall in for a base hit and the
mitts will get the tying run to bat in
the bottom of the seventh hard hit
dansby what a pick second one first two
in the braves winner hang out a gold
star for kyle muller
dansby swanson and the braves bullpen
dansby starts a game-ending double play
and the braves strike first at the start
of this critical series
what a way jeff to strike the
doubleheader a two-nothing shutout win